why now
ask yourself what new technologies
have come out or what technologies have
plummeted in price
so if you were to look at things in your
smartphone like accelerometers and
cameras and processors they're all
getting so cheap that you can do
something really brilliant create a
camera that has ai storage
and a processor in it that's able to do
facial recognition in the camera itself
and then that could open the door
without ever going up to the server and
without having an internet connection it
could just you program your face into it
you walk up to your front door you can
open it so ring doorbells could have
enough technology in them today to send
a video back to you on your mobile phone
if it wasn't for a decade and billions
of smartphones being made a company like
ring could not exist their why now was
how cheap the sensors and cameras and
internet connectivity and wi-fi chips
were
in those don't give yourself too much
credit for the idea
there are good ideas but an idea is not
a company
and what you really want to do is
iterate and iterate on the problem
you're trying to solve
and just be humble about the fact that
nobody invests in ideas or plans today
i haven't seen somebody
raise money just based on an idea
or a plan a little over 10 years
what people are looking for is track
records from founders and teams
world-class products that you were able
to build on a small amount of money and
growing startups that's where funding
occurs today you could have a very
boring business but if it's growing 30
or 40 percent every month you'll have
money thrown at you and if you're
begging folks to hear about your idea
you're doing it wrong
don't worry about your idea worry about
your mvp your minimum viable product
your prototype your mvp
the first iteration of your product
is more valuable
than
a thousand pages of business plan and
500 pages of mock-ups
because we now know as investors when
you show us that prototype that you care
enough to have built it
and that you have the credibility to
write code do the design and make this a
reality and then the next stop is to
have but 10 people using the product
every day and loving it
if you do those two things you make a
product that's great looking and solves
a real problem for 10 people you're
going to get meetings with investors if
you try to get meetings with investors
before you do that
it's probably not going to happen so
that is the test
that you're being challenged with right
now by investors are you
naive
and clueless and believe that people
should take the meeting with you because
of your idea or your business plan
that means you're out of sync with
reality and that there you don't
understand that there's thousands of
people who just build things in the
world on indie hackers or pioneer labs
or in weekend hackathons people are out
there building prototypes all the time
and getting 10 customers to play with
them and those are the people getting
the meetings and you're trying to get a
meeting and asking somebody to think
about your idea or hear about your idea
nobody cares people are too busy there's
too much competition in the world for
you
get focused on building
and get focused on delighting customers
so here are a couple of questions just
to wrap up here that you need to be able
to answer are you able to solve this
problem that you've identified do you
have the expertise does your team have
that expertise do you understand the
problem enough if you don't have the
expertise you're going to need to get it
if you don't have the knowledge you're
going to have to do user interviews so i
don't want to dissuade you from day one
you don't know how to build
a peloton-like product or a tonal like
product okay you are not an engineer
uh you're never built software okay i
don't want to dissuade you but you
should have to ask yourself what is your
experience have you gone to a bunch of
classes for spin classes and used uh
bikes
and how familiar are you with the
existed connected software out there you
get the idea and making hardware maybe
you should go work at a startup that is
doing hardware or you should go work at
a spin class and teach spin for six
months and really understand the
customer base so that informs what you
build in the product
so number one why will you be the person
uniquely qualified to solve this problem
it doesn't mean you have to have spent
10 years
in writing you have to spend 10 years in
the hotel business to create airbnb you
don't have to spend 20 years owning a
taxi company to
create uber in fact some people would
argue fresh eyes on the problem are
better but you should have some
expertise on building the product and
really understand the customers why now
is the second question going to answer
why now why should this product exist
now is there some technology enabling it
three how big is the market always an
important question is this for 10 people
100 people a thousand people do that
bottoms up market sizing okay there's a
thousand people who have the title
social media manager at major companies
and who have 10 people or more working
for them we've identified those thousand
on linkedin we're going to pursue them
and we think those thousand will turn
into ten thousand will turn into a
hundred thousand will turn into a
million people with the job title social
media manager okay great and we actually
did
how to get your total addressable market
on twist episode 1211. so if you want to
go deep dive into total addressable
market just type in this week in
startups episode 1211 into your google
browser and most importantly how are you
going to make money what's the business
model
the business models tend to be pretty
straightforward in our industry your
marketplace you take a percentage of the
commerce done in the marketplace like
ebay
like coinbase like uh airbnb
or you're selling a software product and
you're getting a monthly fee like com
sells a software product consumers or
slack sells a software product to
enterprise finally you're going to want
to be able to interview those potential
customers and gather feedback
listening labs user interviews this is a
whole science to this you can look it up
online you can learn those best
practices it's not really difficult you
basically go talk to somebody and you
ask them probing questions you ask them
to show you how they do things at work
and then write that information down in
your interview sometimes you record it
with a video camera or with audio and
then if you've done ten of them you
might find that six people seven people
all have the same problem
billing so you talk to people who are
running airbnbs or running bed and
breakfast and they say they're all of
them have the problem of finding
customers acquiring new customers maybe
they have billing problems maybe they
have insurance problems who knows what
they're building their website might be
a problem so you solve all those
problems with an airbnb website and be
objective with yourself
you want to understand why this might
work why it wouldn't and you want to be
just candid with what you're capable of
doing and what talent you're going to
need to bring to the table so get
building that mvp
remember startups are not for everybody
90 of them fail but there is no success
like failure if you fail you learn keep
failing keep learning keep trying if 60
70 80 of startups fail you just do three
or four of them you're going to get a
win that's my basic math in all of this
you're going to get a win eventually and
you're going to have a heck of a fun
time doing it if you're the right type
of person who likes to work hard and
create in the world and what are your
choices like are you going to work for
some big giant company and work for
google now optimizing or facebook ads
you know maybe if you need to make a
little money buy your house pay for your
kids school but after that be a little
delusional and start a company
right now linkedin is gonna give you a
hundred dollar credit towards your first
ad campaign i'm telling you the call to
action upfront it's so good linkedin.com
this week in startups to get that
hundred dollar credit towards your first
ad campaign if you want to get a group
of people who are receptive and who are
doing business they're doing business on
linkedin right when you market on
linkedin your message reaches people who
are ready to engage with your business
this means your ad campaign will work as
hard as it can as soon as you launch it
need more evidence to use linkedin
marketing over 78 b2b marketers rate
linkedin as the most effective social
media platform for reaching objectives
because there are over 62 million
decision makers on linkedin you know
that and they mean business linkedin
equals business equals linkedin it's
that simple folks and here's how
linkedin marketing stands out they have
the tools for brand building or lead
generation you can pick you can target
professionals down to their job title
company name and location and you can
engage folks you already know based on
previous site visits or outreach right
so you can do that retargeting thing so
do business where business is done get a
hundy get 100 ad credit right now go to
linkedin.com this week in startups once
again for a hyundai linkedin.com
this week in startups no spaces no
dashes linkedin.com
this week in startups terms and
conditions apply because they're giving
you a hundy